[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 23rd of
November I'm Kate Andrews The Spectators
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show did the government
really cut taxes yesterday I'll speak to
former Chancellor quasi Quang is the
autumn enough to turn the polls around
for the Tory party Katie balls and David
Miles will join me will a humanitarian
pause be an inflection point in the war
in Gaza I'll speak to anel feffer and
Eugene
Rogan why did Peter Hitchens go to jail
I'll speak to the man himself and
finally why you should be reading CS
Lewis with a an
Wilson before we get going subscribe to
The Spectator in our flash sale and
you'll not only get your first 12 weeks
in print and online for1 but you'll also
get a bottle of Johnny Walker Black
Label whiskey absolutely free it's only
available within the UK and you must be
18 or older and a big thank you to our
sponsors cancord genuity wealth
management cancord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer un wavering support during
challenging times to find out more visit
KW wealth.com for more
information first up Jeremy Hunt wanted
yesterday's Autumn statement to prove
that he was a tax cutting chancellor has
he convinced the public and his LPS
including this former Chancellor I'm
joined Now by quasi
quarten quasi thanks for joining
spectator TV you say you say in a piece
for the Daily Telegraph today that you
broadly welcome the measures and the
Autumn statement so what do you broadly
make of it yes I think it was a step in
the right direction and that's what I've
uh written about in the telegraph what I
liked about it was that I think it was
the first time uh since Rishi sunak was
first appointed to the uh the treasury
that we've seen some tax cuts for
business uh um I was very pleased to see
the ni uh cut the ni tax uh cut from 12%
to 10% I was also pleased to see uh
investment allowances you know the
permanent basis of that for business um
and I think that it was the first step
actually to show as they've said all
along uh Rishi has said all along he's a
tax cutting prime minister and I think
this is the first time we've seen an
indication of that so I broadly welcomed
it from that point of view the
Chancellor's phrase yesterday the autumn
statement for growth was reminiscent to
me anyway of the growth plan which is
what you labeled your plan last year
what did you make of it when you heard
those words yesterday well I was
surprised that they uh boldly copied
that language but I think that you know
his plan was a much more tentative one
than the one we had obviously but I
think you know he said that uh and I
think he thinks that given what happened
last year in the markets you know I I
can see the need for caution but the
underlying problem remains the same you
can't simply grow at 0.5 or
1% um and hope to sustain four or 5%
annual growth in public
expenditure um there comes a point where
you either have to increase taxes or or
borrow more which leads to more taxation
in the first in the you know
subsequently so the fundamental problem
Remains the Same we're a relatively low
growth uh country at the moment the fact
that we're growing faster than the Euro
Zone which the remainers hate to be
reminded of for me is neither here nor
there because you essentially we're both
very slow runners and to say that you're
you know the fastest of you know people
among people who can't run very fast is
neither here nor there you got to look
at what's happening in the US and Asia
which are really driving growth right
now you know they're getting 3 4% a year
and we can't simply just stumble along
at one or one and a half% I want to pull
up those growth figures um our viewers
will be able to see the graph now uh the
obr has largely downgraded its forecasts
attached to this Autumn statement for
growth revised them upwards for this
year no longer predicting recession we
haven't seen recession thankfully in the
UK they're predicting .6% growth this
year but next year
.7% um it isn't until the final year of
the forecast that things look slightly
better than expected in March and these
are still not terribly impressive growth
figures and you know if your economy as
I've said is growing let's say at 1%
let's you know give them uh the benefit
of the that 1% um you can't sustain
public uh spending growth at 3 4 5% um
it can't be done and I think you know
what Liz and myself tried to do last
year was actually fundamentally tackle
this growth problem um and I want to see
the government uh perhaps in the budget
this year next year rather uh be
ambitious in that regard but I
understand the tentative steps but at
some point you've got to deliver growth
for our country because otherwise wi you
simply won't be able to sustain public
expenditure you're making this important
point about if you want to cut taxes you
have to deal with the spending side of
equation yes I believe so many people
think that is what was left out of grow
last year um I mean I remember and I
think someon Clark has written about
this all through the leadership campaign
we were looking at spending
reductions um and spending and it's not
actual redu you know for those of you
who are mathematically minded we're not
talking about absolute reductions we're
talking about first order reductions
that is slow the rate of growth of
expenditure um and I think that's really
important because uh you need to be able
to balance uh tax cuts with some
spending restraint doesn't have to be
one for one but you have to show um in
my view that you're going to be um very
restrained uh in terms of the growth of
public expenditure now what the plan
last year was to do um what we
eventually decided to do which I think
was a mistake frankly was to do the tax
cuts first and then have a subsequent
statement outline in the spending path
but I think what should have happened
looking back and hindsight is a
beautiful thing is we should have
delayed the actual statement to November
and then presented I should have
presented a tax cutting plan roughly
along the lines that we did but also W
with a a serious plan for reducing the
rate of growth of public expenditure so
that it there was balance now it
wouldn't have to be pound for pound I
think you know the numbers I looked at
ahead of uh lizz's election as leader
there was a I think a tax cut of about
35 billion so we just stuck to the ni uh
um cut and the um not raising
corporation tax from 19 to 25% that
should we should have left it at that
and then we should have found perhaps
you know 10 to 15 billion of savings
across the the um the spending period
and that would have been a net expansion
of 20 billion in the event we had a 45
billion uh expansion on top of the
energy intervention and I think that
would was that did um that did spook the
market I that's just a fact I want to
ask you a few more questions about the
Autumn statement but just very quickly
on the energy price guarantee that you
brought up and and we can have a photo
of it here for our viewers it was this
table 4.1 in the growth plan in which
markets were being asked to fund about
60 billion pounds per every six months
for that energy price guarantee now to
my knowledge the former prime minister
continues to essentially support that
decision that was necessary do you agree
with her that that was think that it
wasn't actually but actually You' got to
remember also that the OB figures
changed I was very conscious of sort of
so-called 72 billion black hole that
they was leaked um you know ahead of or
just after the the uh the uh the Autumn
statement last year the mini budget if
you want to call it that disappeared
because of fiscal drag so by the
beginning of this year that 72 billion
figure had almost disappeared and as we
saw this year because of again because
of inflation and fiscal drag the numbers
were more benign they were they were
slightly better in terms of the public
finances and I think there was a case
for for simply hanging in there but
obviously I I didn't ultimately take
that decision uh to resign or to be
sacked of course but you think that that
asking the markets for that amount of
money may have been what actually I
think you compound I think we I think I
think there there were just too many
fiscal interventions or too much fiscal
expansionism so it's one thing having
the energy uh package that she announced
and I think broadly the market sort of
understood where that was coming from
but then on top of that to have the 45
billion expansion I think that was that
was something that was that was
difficult to bear and and you know
hindsight is a beautiful thing I think
uh LZ trust was bold I think we were
bold I think it was you know we were
attacking the right question but there
was U I think an interesting uh and
valid questions to be asked about the
delivery in the time scale and things
were unlucky I mean in the sense that
you know just at the moment that the um
the mini budget last year with the
Autumn segement last year landed we were
seeing unpr ented uh interest rate hikes
in the Fed so you know everyone said oh
the you know there's almost dollar
parity it's collapse of Sterling every
currency in the world at that point was
very weak against uh the dollar the Yen
was at a 50-year low the Euro was at its
lowest ever I think so there was an
international context as well but I
think going back to the main point I
think you've got to show some
credibility on spending restraint if
you're going to have a an advanced uh
program of tax cuts i' I've been a rean
I I remember saying that to the Prime
Minister I don't believe that you can
simply just reduce taxes and hope that
they pay for themselves even if that
were true I not enough people believe
that for for for for markets to be
stabilized I think intellectually you've
got to have a discipline and show how
you you're going to restrain public
spending growth um while alling that to
tax cuts I think the two have to go hand
in hand well let me ask you about the
public debt we have another graph we can
pull up here in which the obr has
essentially said that Jeremy Hunt is
playing this very very close to the line
most chancers give themselves much more
Headroom to meet their fiscal Target to
reduce that ratio between debt to GDP um
the obr has actually suggested that it's
only if Jeremy Hunt were to unfreeze
fuel Duty that he might meet his Target
and you know I think there's a lot of
skepticism that that's that's right
that's ever going to happen does this
worry you or do you think that this is
totally sustain able in a G7 country no
I think it's it's it's it's slightly
concerning because the issue that we
face is um thank God we've avoided
recession but God forbid if there is a
recession you'll see the revenues the
tax revenues plummet and typically you
know the what the kin call you know the
automatic stabilizers public expend
expenditure will go up so the fiscal
Headroom that you have in a in a not
even a recession in a world where you
have essentially flat growth is very
narrow um and I mean the fundamental
problem poses itself you know how can
you sustain essentially Flatline
economic growth or 1% economic growth
when public expenditure is going up four
5% a year and until you actually resolve
that I.E until you actually get growth
or you reduce spending you you're you're
on a fundamentally unsustainable path
the Tory party sent out a tweet
yesterday uh from the conservative
account which read conservatives cut
taxes it's just what we do uh hailing
the largest ever tax cut for workers do
you think this was a tax cutting Autumn
statement and by that I mean if we
compare the 10 billion pounds worth of
tax cuts for National Insurance to
what's happening because of the six-year
freeze on thresholds which the obr
estimates is going to rake in upwards of
40 billion pounds of tax hikes is it
really reasonable for the Tory party to
be claiming that they are cutting taxes
I think every fiscal statement in a way
does juggle in in in that way so I
remember last year where we did have
actual tax cuts um we also froze the
thresholds because that was something
which um was obviously going to get
revenue and the so-called 72 billion
hole as I said disappeared because
inflation was higher for longer and
there was the fiscal drag was even more
effective so you're right to say that in
in absolute terms the wasn't um
necessarily net net a tax card well in
absolute terms we can we can pull up the
graph here the tax burden Remains the
Same we're still on track for a postwar
high yeah so so again this goes back to
the fundamental problem you're not going
to be able to reduce the tax burden if
you can't grow the economy substantially
that's the that's the conundra you said
something interesting there you said
last year when we really cut taxes are
you emphasizing the extent of the tax
cut or are you not so convinced by these
particular me I mean anyone anyone with
two eyes in their head who can read can
see that you know the measures we end we
had last year were very substantial and
that was arguably what um the markets
were were were concerned about on top of
the energy intervention as you say last
uh sorry yesterday there were some tax
cuts but they weren't of the scale and
and you know someone like Jeremy Hunt
would probably say well look what
happened last year we had to proceed
with more caution this year and that's
clearly what he's done you wrote in your
Telegraph piece that some of the
measures in the Autumn statement
reminded you of Gordon Brown who you say
tinkered endlessly with the tax code
it's not obviously the most flattering
comparison to bestow upon the government
but I try and I try and be balanced I
mean broadly I welcome the measures I
think it was the first time certainly
with richy sunak at the helm that we've
we've seen reductions and you know let's
not kid ourselves Rishi sunak would have
been all over the Autumn statement I
mean I don't think there was a comma in
that that he wouldn't have had uh some
input into um but but I think if you
look at the large list I mean I saw some
things like you know the hundred 110
million for nutrient balance or whatever
it was there was a you know some 7
million for an anti-Semitism udit which
is you know very laudable but again
micro uh expenditure I think there was a
3 million for an anti-racist uh you
policy or program there were lots of
little micro measures and you know
having written in newspapers I think I
even did something for this magazine at
the time um you know what that did
remind me of Gordon Brown but you got to
remember uh a lot of the politicals
debate in the UK is about the ministers
you know the the chancellor did this the
Prime Minister did that you know the
secretary of state did that but actually
underneath it all there there's a a
permanent semi-permanent civil service
and so a lot of the style a lot of the
um preoccupations of the Departments
last a lot longer than the individual
ministers I mean I was in treasury for
God knows five weeks Jeremy hun will
will be probably even if richy wins we
probably be moved on I don't know um
we're we're there for quite a short time
but actually there's a continuity with
the with the Civil Service that um you
know Yes Minister famously that TV
program famously uh sha a light on but
people not aware of um and I think the
style of Gordon Brown's approach um is
still is still very much you know part
of the treasury part of the treasury's
makeup um and so it it's not surprising
to see uh some of his style reflected in
in statements even even today you've
made a big point of saying it's just
simply not sustainable to have growth
around 1% and to have public expenditure
rising and rising and rising and we know
it will not least because of the
National Health Service and the state
pension we know these costs are only
going to go up and I'd like to say Kate
I mean you know the polls are suggesting
some sort of Labor government I'm not
convinced that's true but let's let's
say take for granted that labor get in
their propensity to cut
spending I think is zero I think they're
very unlikely but I want to ask you
about the Tory Prospect because one
could look at this past government all
its iterations from Boris Johnson to Liz
trust toishi sunak and they could also
say well the chances of a Tory
government cutting public spending are
virtually zero and this focus on growth
is so that ideally we don't have to
really cut public spending but is this
Tory government showing signs that it
will go for the supply side reforms it's
not talking about housing it's not
talking about serious off gains in the
Health Service um I take your point
perhaps labor wouldn't cut spending but
can can you or or anyone else in the
Tory party at the moment credibly say
that the Tory party would do that I I
think you ask a huge question and I also
believe that this is the this is the the
really the the tough stuff you know
anyone can spend more money anyone can
announce tax cuts but I think for the
Tory right my free market friends
they've really got to ask questions
about spend spending and they've really
got to be bold about spending and and
and restraint and I think that's
something that we missed last year
certainly the markets I mean Liz has
said oh well we it was all fully costed
it wasn't um well certainly the markets
didn't believe that the people examining
that and they didn't believe that so I
think we've got to be credible about
that and you know an excuse for the last
few years we did have a covid you know
Global pandemic which actually was the
one thing that blew apart any kind of
spending restraint because uh you know
we spent something like 300 billion in
one year on the covid support now we can
argue whether that was the right thing
or the wrong thing but that's what
happened and much of the debate around
public spending uh now certainly in the
2020s um has been driven by what
happened in terms of the covid
interventions has put put emergency
intervention aside it's that day-to-day
spending that the Tory government seems
to like to raise no but you see the you
can't really put it to one side because
certainly when I started in Parliament
you know the the the welfare budget was
was big bigger than the health budget
that isn't the case now the NHS spending
I think is the biggest single item in
public expenditure and that's obviously
related not only to demographic uh
demand uh ongoing demand but also to
covid so I don't think you can
disaggregate the effects of covid on
public expenditure uh from as you put it
the current day-to-day need we won't
speculate about the polls who knows
what's going to happen next year but uh
as already mentioned in this t we've had
several versions of leadership we've had
Boris Johnson's cakeism we've had Liz
truss's let's call it radical optimism
uh we have rishy cak really getting into
the details almost regardless of what
happens next year what do you think the
next vision for the T party should be I
think we've got to be intellectually
more engaged with the harder questions
you know for me yes we all believe in
tax cuts uh we all believe or many of us
believe in a small smaller state but how
do we actually get there which taxes
should we be cutting first uh there's an
argument and I that's what I liked about
the Autumn statement yesterday was that
they were reducing business taxes bit of
uh income taxes to encourage the
investment but there's got to be a
staged and processed look at uh tax
reductions but also a question that I
know you're very interested in about
what the state should provide and also
finding greater efficiencies because
it's very much the labor argument that
by spending more money somehow you get
better outcomes but we've got to be much
more rigorous about public expenditure
and that's a debate that you know
looking back I wish we'd had last year
I'd have been you know we'd have been I
think better to be bolder on public we'
have had a lot of flack from the left
obviously but I think we've got to be
level with people on on public
expenditure quasi thanks for joining
me continuing on the Autumn statement
I'm joined Now by Katie balls and David
Miles an economist with the office for
Budget responsibility Katie and David
thanks for joining me Katie you write
for the the magazine this week that
Jeremy Hunt's Autumn statement may be
too little too late what you mean by
that well it's one of three options I
pose in my question um effectively this
is uh what MPS have wanted R to do for a
long time which is cut tax wanted to do
when he was Chancellor and he was prime
minister they wanted him to do it but
every time Rashid St has always said I
am a low tax Tory each time he says I
think his Ms have believed him a little
bit less um he's made the case that he
had to in the Public Finance aners are
right and this Autumn statement I think
is meant to be that moment the start of
a new chapter by which from here they
will try and reduce the tax but um the
fact that they have chosen to do so now
I think if you just look to what Jeremy
Hunt and Rich s was saying a few weeks
ago um suggesting tax cuts would have to
wait till the spring that wasn't just
trying to throw journalists off the
scent I think there was a feeling uh
that they weren't sure that would be the
Headroom and then I also think it's a
combination of having more Headroom than
they expected Ed and also having some
political necessity because Rishi sunk
is in a place where his party is pretty
much tanking in the polls and his MPS
are getting very anxious um so they've
chosen to move now the reason I think
that for some this is going to be too L
too late is even though the National
Insurance cut for employees will come
into effect in January which think is
earlier than many would have expected um
people still dealing a cost of living
crisis you have the fact that the
freezing of the thresholds means fiscal
drag uh is something which is going to
negate I think at least some of that tax
cut people still feel as though they're
paying a lot more than they were a while
ago and therefore by the time you get to
the next election and I think there will
probably be more tax cuts before the
next election will people feel as though
they better off and I think that's the
big question David A lot of people are
speculating that this is the start not
the end of the tax cutting agenda uh but
the obr makes clear uh in its report
around the Autumn statement that the
chancellor has spent almost all of his
fiscal Headroom this time round now
perhaps the combination of inflation um
and and the freeze on on thresholds will
give you even more fiscal Headroom in
the March budget but he's already pretty
close to the line I mean you're right
that the the head room at the end of the
forecast Horizon um is pretty small in
an economy that's three trillion 3,000
billion you have Headroom of on our
Central for about 13 billion so it's
it's kind of wafer
thin I think it's difficult position to
start from though because we've had
borrowing deficits until recently
running up 5% it's only a little bit
lower than that 5% of GDP deficit stock
debt has gone up a great deal in recent
years you're trying to stabilize that
starting from a position with a fiscal
deficit what our forecast for the OB
suggest is that the way that that
deficit comes down is that you squeeze
government spending relative to GDP over
the next 5 years by a couple of
percentage points of GDP and you
increase the tax takeout of GDP by a
couple of percent of GDP and that
squeezes that deficit down from 5% of
GDP which would itself have meant the
debt carried on Rising if you stayed
there to about 1% of GDP five years down
the road that's a hard road to go down
and it
involves tough decisions on spending and
an increasing tax take care to GDP and
that just about stabilizes the stock of
debt so there there was there's no easy
way to go forward from here given where
we start from uh Katie the Tory party is
hailing its biggest ever tax cut for
workers its biggest ever one-off tax cut
for business um but not everybody is so
convinced if you look at where the tax
burdens actually headed to it is still
on track for that postwar high how RoR
andp is responding to the narrative and
what's actually been done so I think
there is just a sense of relief that
finally there is a tax cut plural even
in front of them because it has been put
off for such a long time so I think the
initial reaction was quite cheery on
that front and the fact that when Jeremy
Hunt addressed Tory MPS he hinted again
heavily that this was just the beginning
and there'll be further tax cuts I think
when it comes to income tax versus
National Insurance I think The Narrative
of a budget for the workers means that
even though National Insurance is
probably a little bit less of a retail
offer um in terms of what they think
they can sell on the doorstep they think
there at least a coherent narrative and
there is relief that they didn't make
their main giveaway inheritance tax as a
cut because I think there was a worry
that if you were just doing that which
was floated at one point um it would
really play into certain stereotypes
about the Tory party but it's very much
a oh this is a good start but what have
you got next and I think the point that
Jeremy Hunt tried to make when he
addressed MPS at the 22 committee is
that they shouldn't pretend they haven't
raised tax because I think in lots of
these discussions oh the tax burden so
high the Tories have been power so long
it's shocking but there's also been a
pandemic and if you look at where lots
of that cost is coming you have fur and
you have the support for energy and
Jeremy Hunt said let's not pretend we
have not not been raising taxes because
we can defend the things we did you can
defend the decisions you made on ferow
on energy support but we're now at the
point we can argue these decisions uh
were making and being done the right
time and they're not going to be
reversed like with the trusts mini
budget um so I think it's trying
actually to Fred these parts together so
you have a coherent narrative by the
time of the next election now not all
voters and not all Tor MPS particularly
bu that argument they're just annoyed at
the tax burden but I think that's what
they want to get to
say um David UK living standards are
falling dramatically so why are they so
low is it all the pandemic or is
something else going
on well it's it's a combination of
things as Katie just said there's two
big things that have hit us in recent
years um there's the pandemic that was
very bad for GDP the economy for
standards of living increased debt a
great deal and really necessitated then
a rise in taxes if you're going to stop
debt from rising so that's one thing and
then just as ones coming out of covid we
get this huge increases in imported
Energy prices which the government I
mean for good reasons tried to cush in
the blow of that on
households um but you can't keep doing
that
and so it's that combination of hit hits
to the economy hits the standard of
living um
wages have only just begun to match the
rate of inflation but they've been
lagging behind it for the last 18 months
or so so when you get these big hits to
the economy really there isn't anywhere
to hide I mean they're just a reduction
in the standard of living of the people
of this country now you might hope that
over time you get a growth grow in
productivity we just get more productive
at producing things and that grows you
out of the problem but we've been hoping
for that for 15 years since the
financial crisis and it hasn't really
happened
now one could be optimistic that the
last of the big shocks for a while
anyway is behind us so we might see some
productivity growth and standards of
living will rise and I think that that's
that's plausible that's not not just
wishful thinking but it hasn't happened
yet and that's why standard of living
have fallen and will fall a bit more yet
Katie what do you think the government
realistically expects to get out of
these announcements from The public's
perspective do you think they're
expecting to see a big shift in the
polls I don't think that they're really
expecting a single event to have a big
shift in the polls clearly I think tax
cuts are seen as a not only a vote
winner in the long term but also a
dividing line of Labor um and often Rach
revs and Jeremy Hans sound quite similar
on the economy um so I think it's going
back to basic principles and getting
that path for the next election which is
if the Tories have spare money they will
use it to cut taxes while Rachel Reeves
I think is has said the tax burden of
working people is too much and it does
not feel as though she was going to
oppose some of these tax cuts she would
I think oppose an inheritance tax cut um
is it the case that Labor's priority if
they do manage to grow the economy and
get more money is tax cuts or is it
public spending so you start to go back
to those traditional dividing lines I
think if they were just going for
with this Autumn statement you probably
wouldn't have had the super deduction
the full expensing made permanent that
is the most expensive measure in the
entire Autumn statement as I think one
Tor MP said it's not particularly sexy
um when it comes to selling it on the
doorstep but is something that if you
look at comments by the CBI I think lots
of think tanks more to the right and
also sumon labor they think is just a
sensible thing to do for growing the
economy so I think that's more of a
long-term decision whereas if you were
just thinking what do we do right now to
swing the polls and give us a best
chance you would potentially done income
tax and National Insurance and so forth
uh more of a focus on personal taxes um
I think in when you get near an election
they will try and do more with that um
but therefore I think this is about
actually having a coherent growth
strategy while also politically trying
to combine that we're doing something to
try and change the polls but it's not
the only reason for this budget David
there's of course a difference between
the narrative that's put out this is a
huge cutting event and then actually
what people feel and what what really
jumped out at me um from the obr's
report is that the obr has emphasized
the extent that fiscal drag is taking
place Millions more people um by the end
of the forecast are going to be dragged
into income tax into the higher rate of
income tax even into that
45p bracket I think that's about 400,000
people um and people are going to be
feeling worse off even with this tax cut
some people are not going to be feeling
dayto day as if they are in a better
position than they were a few years ago
uh that is true uh the the impact of
freezing the thresholds which is what
really pushes people
into paying tax for the first time or
paying tax at a higher rate actually
generates lots of Revenue over the next
five years I think the OB put it at 44
billion compared to it's it's 40 OD
billion that's right now not not all of
that is income tax on labor income but
most of it is is and therefore the the
threshold
freezing generates more tax revenue than
the National Insurance contribution cut
Cuts tax revenue of course it's also
true that since the threshold freeze was
already in place the marginal impact of
cutting the national insurance rate is
is to reduce taxes so it's both true
that taxes have been cut labor income
taxes have been cut in the budget
but that taxes on labor income and the
effective tax rate on labor income will
likely be rising they're both true K and
David thanks for joining me in this
week's cover piece anel feffer ask
whether Israel can keep the support of
its allies as it fights a war in Gaza he
says the idf's window of legitimacy
could be closing to discuss Angel joins
me now alongside Oxford historian Eugene
Rogan and shall you write for this
week's magazine that for now Israel is
being allowed to fight this war in Gaza
but pressure has been growing from the
International Community to ease fighting
we now have a humanitarian pause give us
your
update well as we're speaking right now
we don't know yet when the pause will
begin it was supposed to begin on
Thursday
morning uh as part of the agreement
brokered by uh the hamas's Qatari
patrons uh and there was supposed to be
on from Thursday morning a truce with
which would last of 4 days during which
every night Hamas was supposed to
release about 12 of the hostages that
they've been holding now for seven weeks
uh for various reasons that we're not
quite clear yet Hamas hasn't yet signed
the deal and as part of that deal they
were supposed to already have given a
list of U of of Hostage to be released
tonight so that list hasn't arrived
Hamas haven't yet committed to the deal
um the Israeli side is saying that these
are just some technical things that are
still being dealt with in in Doha the
Qatari capital and will probably happen
tomorrow but as we're speaking it's
still not happening yet Eugene this
humanitarian pause is supposed to allow
for the exchange of 50 hostages for 150
Palestinian prisoners what do you make
of the potential
deal well I think for many people on the
Palestinian side they're hoping it's a
an inflection point
that is going to lead towards an
evolution away from the military phase
of the campaign and move into a
diplomatic phase 50 hostages out of an
estimated 240 will leave 190 lives as
yet unaccounted for and apparently as
part of the deal agreed there is a
possibility of extending day by day this
truce in return for the release of
another 10 hostages a day so I think
that there is a possibility that we
might be moving into a new phase it's
going be very difficult for Israel to
persuade the International Community
that a humanitarian pause followed by a
return to carpet bombing is going to be
a sustainable future and this conflict
has gone on already much longer than the
past Wars that Israel has had with Hamas
in Gaza and the pressure is building in
the International Community for an end
to the suffering on the Palestinian side
so the pressures are there and I think
the way in which the the truth itself
plays out will determine whether this is
indeed an inflection point or whether
we're going back towards another stage
of outright armed conflict andelle what
has the reaction been like within Israel
to this humanitarian pause who is
supporting it and who is opposing
it well many Israelis are simply waiting
to see those children and and and and
their mothers come back home across the
board after 7 weeks of uncertainty and
Israelis are also are also convinced and
almost all the polls are saying this uh
quite clearly that this is just a very
temporary pause not an inflection point
uh Israel has no choice but to to try
and eliminate hamas's military
capability that's been done to a certain
degree over the last seven weeks but
it's still far from over this is just
this is not a ceasefire this is not an
end to the war against Hamas it's going
to continue
almost immediately after the truce is
over there will be some International
pressure but so far Joe Biden and the
main leaders of Europe rishy sunak and
and and Os Olive Schultz are um are
standing up for what's right and are
supporting Israel on this and you we've
even seen in Britain that despite the
the really nasty protests we've seen on
the street they don't represent most of
the British public K starma who's been
standing upright against this as well
against any ceasefire has gone up in the
in the ratings in in Britain the last
few weeks so it doesn't look as if
there's a real uh uh pressure on Israel
to stop the war there'll be some
probably in the media and people like
Eugene obviously who don't like the idea
of Israel of destroying Hamas will
continue saying that there should be a
ceasefire but it's not going for weeks
at least after the truth there'll still
be an Israeli campaign against Hamas to
to the point where Israel feels that it
can that that that Hamas is no longer a
threat in the Israeli communities on the
border of Gaza can go can return home
Eugene your thoughts on
that well I mean I my thoughts are
really Irrelevant in the sense that I
can reflect What I Hear From a Distance
quite removed from where Anam is V
viewing things from Israel and I I think
the immediacy of the events when you
view them from Israel is quite different
from when you view them from Oxford all
I would say is that there is I think
diminishing support for a conflict that
continues to inflict such high uh
casualties on civilians that bear no
guilt for hamas's atrocities and I do
think that that will put pressure on how
much Israel can continue to do we've
already reached a point where the kill
ratio of Israeli casualties versus those
of the civilians of Gaza is 10 to one
and one can't continue to continue a
military operation inflicting those
levels of violence and not expect push
back as though there is a kind of dual
standard of of life here and there has
to be a day after to this at some point
someone's going to have to go in and
address governance in Gaza in a place
where there are 2.2 million people most
of whom won't have a place to live and
who have no means to provide for
themselves and the longer the armed you
know the military campaign goes on the
harder the day after will be so those
are real constraints My Views
notwithstanding and shelle is Israeli
government actually feeling the pressure
to change the way that it's fighting or
is this mostly noise from Israel's
perspective it is mainly noise the
problem when we address what the Israeli
government is doing is that there isn't
really an Israeli government in the
sense as one set policy or strategy here
the Israeli government is was already
quite dysfunctional before the October 7
Massacre it's been almost it's been
dysfunctional more or less from when it
was sworn in at the end of the last year
it's a it's a far right there a group of
far right Ultra religious parties and Li
could party which has ceased to be much
more than the's uh platform and there
isn't really any real strategy making
within that government there is strategy
making within Israeli defense
establishment but as since they're not
the ones who are making the ultimate
decisions that should be the politicians
the you it's really much of a it's not
much of a strategy that Israel can work
with going forward and the real problem
and and this is where I totally agree
with with Eugene is what happens with
the with the civilian population in Gaza
because Hamas is for 16 and a half years
in control of of Gaza has built its
military infrastructure to the length
and breadth and depth of of every part
of the civilian Fabric in Gaza so
there's no question that in in an
operation which is which is aimed at at
dismantling and destroying Hass military
infrastructure there has to be a a dual
strategy of what to do with a 2 point
three million people living in Gaza
there is there are there aren't many
safe a is there that's that's of course
true
and the Israeli military began this
campaign by warning people to to go
south of w Gaza then recently last few
days they've been warning people to move
away from kanun which is where the Hamas
leadership is now hold uh you know
they're hold in
underground it's also the hometown of
most of the Hamas leaders uh at the same
time there isn't enough of a strategy
from Israel how to deal with the two 2.3
million uh citizens who can't leave Gaza
Egypt Egypt refuses to allow them even
temporary respite across the border I
think what we will see in two or three
weeks is much more pressure on Israel to
deliver some kind of a plan for the for
the for the uh civilians there and this
is where and this is what I wrote in my
piece in the Spector this is where I see
the main threat to the support for
Israel is when I think people like Biden
and the other Western leaders who have
so far still are giving Israel very
significant support when they realize
that Nal government is incapable seems
incapable of delivering that dual
strategy not just the military side but
also the humanitarian side this is where
they'll start getting anxious and I
think some of that pressure will start
may result not necessarily in Israel's
ending the military campaign but in some
political changes within the netan
government we're already hearing threats
from some of the farri parties in the
government saying that we won't agree
for any type of Aid to the Palestinians
and if Israel continues to even have
this dialogue with the West over how to
do that they may withdraw from the from
the Coalition and I think that will
probably be the the most the most
important point in this war as far as
Israel's strategy changing but for that
to happen I think there'll also first to
have first have to be some kind of
political change may have to ditch some
of his partners he may even be forced to
resign himself but that that's how I see
the pressure working out rather than the
pressure preventing Israel from
continuing the military campaign
pressure forcing Israel to add also
humanitarian strategy and that will
probably mean political change within
the Israeli
government and shellin Eugene thanks for
joining spectator
TV Peter Hitchens has learned about the
British justice system in a very
personal way recently he's here now
Peter thanks for joining spectator TV
pleasure you spent some time in prison
lately tell us about that well it's very
unpleasant uh but I volunteered for it
so I can't complain if you can't take a
joke you shouldn't have joined Channel 4
came to me and said would I take part in
a reality experiment in as near as could
possibly be recreated to a a real prison
they' hired a number of former actual
prisoners and a number of actual retired
prison officers and they also hired a
recently decommissioned prison in
shury and they proposed to put us all
together those people and about seven
minor celebrities such as I am uh in
these circumstances and film us all the
time see what happened see how we took
it and I've been quite trench about
prisons over my life and I still hold
quite strong opinions about them and I
thought it would be cowardly of me to
say no so I said yes a lot of people put
up with it for a whole week I would have
put up with it for a week if I been
asked but they they they kept me out
until the final four days and that I
have to tell you was quite enough I was
very pleased when it was over there was
no there were moments of laughter and uh
and what you might call bonding and and
quite emotional moments but it was never
at any stage of pleasure and never
something that you wanted to last any
longer than it did to go back to the
beginning when Channel 4 approached you
about this you must have had some
reservations what made your principal so
to speak uh Trump the reservations you
might have had well I didn't really I in
a long life I've leared that that
opportunities often come to you in un
alluring ways uh and very you might as
well take them quite often things which
which appear oning to begin with
Journeys that you might or might not
undertake places you might or might not
go to uh it's almost always worth saying
yes so probably I was the least likely
person to have misgivings about it you
said you spent four days in shury prison
how real did this simulation feel often
very real m uh the building is as it
would be and they'd be very carefully
made it as as like the real thing as
possible the officers behaved as far as
possible as they would have done and the
prisoners I think in May rather nobly
because they they saw it as a way of of
of making some restitution for what
they' done these are all former
prisoners who stopped being criminals
really entered into the spirit of it
they gave us as much as possible what we
would have got if it had been real now
we knew that it was most unlikely that
any serious violence would take place uh
we knew other characteristics of real
prison weren't there and we also knew
that ultimately we could get out you
could you could press the chicken switch
and someone would come and take you away
for it was very dis very much
discouraged and you were told it would
it would be very unwelcome I don't think
anybody actually did that but you knew
ultimately but in fact you quite quickly
forgot once you were in there that it
was it was possible to get out you
became very convinced you were there by
compulsion You' lost all power over your
life and the architecture the power of
architecture was one of the most
underestimated Arts I always go on about
it but I have to say being in a
Victorian prison built with with the
purpose of impressing on the convicted
prisoner that he has done wrong uh is
quite uh is quite an experience the very
bricks are talking to you the shape of
the archway of the door the tunnel shape
of the cell the high window with a view
of nothing except a chimney and the
famous little tent of blue the prisoners
call the sky all that does have an
impact on you and the clanging of heavy
iron and this the stamp of of booted
feet on cast iron Landings it it comes
home to you and and makes you behave and
feel differently quite
lonely uh and quite downcast you
mentioned in your piece that the
experience felt almost religious was
part of that the setting I think yes I
think but I think any any any serious uh
experience of of unpleasantness of
solitude of self-doubt uh and fear
because there was some fear involved in
it I think it turns the Mind towards God
if there's any room in your mind for God
it's all these things will turn your
mind towards him I wanted to ask if you
were afraid were you consistently afraid
were there specific moments were you the
moments when I was afraid and these were
people who had obviously been capable in
their past lives of great violence I
didn't know who they were we got a very
sketchy introduction to who they were
they looked in many cases quite
frightening there were occasions when I
I'm my very voice annoys people uh and
it does I have to
be as I've written in the article I have
to be careful on public transport later
at night speaking as I do my manner the
things that I say they annoy people and
I wasn't totally sure I don't want to
cast any slur on anybody uh because in
fact was I got all of generosity from
the four prisoners but the beginning of
it I really wasn't sure where I stood
with him and I thought it was perfectly
possible I might have an accident on the
stairs well I'm sure spec TV Watchers
will be delighted to be listening to you
Peter um I want to talk about one
session where you spoke with an
ex-convict about drugs and addiction
tell our viewers what happened in that
very confrontational session well I
didn't I I have two very unpopular
opinions one one that addiction two
addiction doesn't exist no I have lots
but on this subject I have two
particularly unpopular ones one is
addiction doesn't exist which doesn't uh
and it's it's an attempt to abolish free
will the whole the whole use of the term
in in the way that it is used in English
language which is apart from everything
else extremely variable and the other is
that marijuana is not a soft and safe
drug that anybody can take and without
harm but it is in fact probably the most
dangerous of all the drugs I decided I
didn't want to because I know it can get
very boring I didn't want to have a
rabit Addiction in prison as I was sure
that the the the idea that that there
was there is no real free will that
we're not really responsible for our
actions would be pretty popular among ex
prisoners and not one I'd be I'd have an
easy time dissuading them of but on the
other hand when people started talking
about marijuana as a soft drug I thought
here I am this may get onto television I
can't sit here here it would be cowardly
to sit here and keep my mouth shut so I
said that what I think that it's an
incredibly Dangerous Drug and a number
of people became extremely angry with
immensely strong and also it destroys
the lives of children I can focus on
things I'm totally focused on things on
weed what you talking how did it end
well it ended with them storming out on
in that scene but afterwards for for
more than a few hours I was getting
pretty nasty looks from some of the
people
involves Peter I don't know if you'll
remember this this was years ago I was
still in Think Tank world you and I
exchanged some emails about the gender
pay Gap yes I do remember and I remember
after almost every email you'd sign off
your name and PS you're still wrong
about drugs just so I remember just so I
was clear that we didn't agree on it
it's it's it's a the the the whole
attitude of of intelligent educated
people towards drugs in our society is
an extraordinary thing and it's done as
far as I concerned an enormous amount of
harm so I keep at it where I I see any
signs of Hope if I think you should be
you should be flattered that I thought
you were worth the effort well clear you
made very clear on on only on particular
topics we'll have that debate another
time sure um my last question to you
Peter is whether or not your views on
British prisons have changed since no
because they're not what people think
they are I've never been a lot of people
up for the rest of their lives bread and
water uh flogging person I don't think
there's any point in that I think la
prison sentences are futile they destroy
the souls of those who subject you to
them I've seen inside quite a lot of
prisons and having done that you can't I
think really be human and believe that
sending people to prison for very long
periods of time is normally Justified
obviously there are exceptional cases
where people have simply be kept off the
streets but but I personally would
rather be dared uh than spend 25 years
in a in a in a prison and that that's
just an expression ex of absolute
opinion from what I've seen of them so
I'm not in favor of that I think prisons
should be
austere uh I think they should involve a
lot of hard work and I think that they
should be full of the power of the state
the problem with prisons is that they're
tough in the wrong way uh they're not
austere they're squalid uh they're
chaotic despite the efforts of the
hugely out number of prison officers who
whose role in this is so often
completely underestimated and who and
who keep things from becoming to Al un
civilized in a way which ought to be
more valued but they are chaotic uh they
are increasingly under the control of
the inmates they're full of drugs and
they're full of suicide and they're full
of uh of completely uncontrolled
violence and therefore there is no in
the place where the law sends people
there is no rule of law in fact there is
no rule of authority and so they're
completely unfit for the for the job
they're supposed to do so I would have
them say back under the control of the
authorities
places of Punishment Due punishment of
responsible persons as we used to call
it by the state not people being
punished by other criminals for not
fitting in with them which is what you
get and that you you would have to have
and this of course reflects Society
outside you would have to have a total
exclusion of drugs but it's very hard to
exclude drugs from prison when society
makes toal effort to exclude them from
itself free people can take drugs it's
not surprising that prisoners are taking
them this is actually my last question
to you Peter
did it give you more or less faith in
the rehabilitation system after prison
given that you were in there with EXC
convicts these are people who had now
left prison they were back in there
presumably they were asked by Channel 4
to take on the role of acting like
prisoners so that they could have the
simulation but in terms of the
conversations you were having the
interactions how did it you your your
how did it change your views about
Rehabilitation well Rehabilitation like
addiction doesn't exist there is no such
thing nor any record of ever having
happen people can rehabilitate people
grow up and mature and tire of crime or
they get or they they cease to be able
to run fast enough to get away after
they've committed it but I'm not in any
case in favor of trying to change
people's characters the idea of
Rehabilitation of working on someone to
make him a different person seems to me
to be totalitarian in a free Society you
punish people for wrong acts uh and make
it plain to them that if they do them
again they'll be punished again and you
also make it plain to other people that
if they do these wrong acts they too
will be punished that's how free Society
treats the the people in it who
inevitably
transgress I the whole idea of
reabilitation is repulsive to me and I I
wouldn't be in favor of it if I believe
it happened but no I don't it doesn't
change my view on that at all can an
individual choose to rehabilitate
themselves well I say what do you mean
by the word individuals can choose to
stop doing bad things and often
do uh but they do that for many reasons
they learn for instance that it's
disastrous for their family life they
learn that it strangers from their
children they learn that prison however
strong and tough you are is never going
to be a nice place and they want to
return to it uh they change their lives
while remaining the same people and that
suits me I don't I say I want people to
remain free men and women I don't want
but that's the catch it sounds like
broken it sounds like you're saying they
can change their behavior but not change
their character I guess I'm just
questioning whether not perhaps a person
could choose to change their character
could chose change you have to ask
somebody else it's not something I know
anything about fair enough I seem to
have been stuck with the same character
all my life Peter thanks for joining
me and finally the writer aan Wilson
writes in this week's magazine that 60
years after his death we need CS Lewis
more than ever before Andrew joins me
now Andrew thanks for joining me it's
now 60 years after the death of CS Lewis
what kind of a man was he um
oldfashioned I think is the first thing
to say even by the standards of 196 63
which most people agree was a kind of
turning point in history he was fixed in
the pre-ir world
war Outlook really I mean I think that
that's in a sense the most important
thing about him he was born in Northern
Ireland which is twice a conservative
minded place anyway and he was a teacher
too what did he teach he was a Dawn at
Oxford he was a university teacher he
initially taught philosophy at his old
College University College and then
after a year he became the Engish
literature tutor at mlin College which
he did for decades and then towards the
end of his life um which was a short
life Oxford was incredibly important to
him he was incredibly inspired Oxford
was Central to him uh his friends all
nearly all came from Oxford he scarcely
left Oxford until he got that job in
Cambridge and in those days there was a
railway line between Oxford and
Cambridge they hadn't acted it otherwise
I don't think he'd have taken a job
really he would you think he might have
stayed I'm sure he would cuz he went he
went home to his house in Oxford every
every weekend right uh you start your
piece for the magazine this week writing
about how Lewis RIS Scandal because he
spent time living with an older woman
what was his relationship to Mrs well as
he was training to go to the
trenches uh they were put in keable
college the officers who were the young
officers who were training and it was
alphabetic Lord L for Lewis and then
next boy in the in the adjoining bed was
told Moore Patty Moore he was an Irish
boy like LS himself and they formed a
friendship and they had this agreement
which seemed like a kind of um almost a
joke that if one of them died in the war
the other would look after the the
surviving parent in Lewis's case he
didn't have a mother surviving he his
mother died when he was nine which in
again you say what was important about
him that was in a way the crucial
psychological factor in his
life uh padmore was killed uh and Lewis
who' stayed one weekend with them in
Bristol came home and formed this
passionate attachment to Mrs Moore M as
he told her named after her favorite
Suite which was a sticky mint um and
Jane Moos which is her real name and he
set up house together in just outside
Oxford in a a place called the ks near
headington KS Stone fory this isn't his
only relationship with a woman that has
grabbed headlines over the years you
also write about his late marriage to
Joy davidman tell us about that well
just doing a a little bit about Mrs
Moore it it was a relationship which
unraveled they lived together and um the
sleeping Arrangements which you can
still see at his house the Cs Le study
center at the children she slept in a
big bed bed and he slept in a little bed
in the same room uh but after he had a
religious experience and became a
Christian having been an
Atheist uh she was Furious and one can
only assume that one of the things he
decided to do when he became religious
was to give up carnal relations with Mrs
Moore but of course that's that's only
an inference she used to shout abuse at
him out of the window as he crept off to
Holy Communion he then became this quite
famous Christian apologist and he used
to get dozens of fan letters
particularly from the United States and
one of them was from this woman called
Joy davidman who was in an unhappy
marriage who was struggling with
alcoholism which was also something very
much present in Lewis's
family and who had lately herself moved
from being a position of communist
atheism to broadly speaking Christianity
very much inspired by him and and so she
came over to see him with these two
little
boys uh having escaped this violent and
unhappy marriage and in the course of
that period She got divorced from her
husband
Lewis uh wanting to give her a passport
to England offered to marry her really
very early on in the relationship at at
the time it just seemed like an
arrangement they weren't living together
but somehow or another and it is
extremely touching I think because
they're not very beautiful people
they're not stylish people they're late
middle-aged he was a overweight uh very
very heavy
drinker um chain smoker 60 cigarettes a
day oh my gosh uh with on top of his
pipes which were constantly being lit
and relit um and she was a hard drinking
uh foulmouthed
uh modern kind of person really not the
sort of person you expect of light and
they fell in love it's as simple as that
I think really uh all his male cronies
he was in this little circle called the
inklings um people like Jr Tolen Hugo
Dyson Neville cogil the great cha
scholar they were all horrified um Dyson
quoting from aello used to say CID fate
that gave the to the
mo
um but um they were even more horrified
when when he decided he wanted to marry
joy and he expected them to stop being
um male cronies and to join him with his
domestic life he had never shown the
slightest interest they were all married
people except for Neville Cel um he
never shown the slightest interest in
their wives their children their family
lives and he suddenly expected them to
be interested in joy and he was obsessed
by joy and it did mean the end of his
friendships with most of his men friends
actually oh wow so how did she affect
his work clearly she affected his life
hugely but how did she affect his work
um well it's a hard question to answer
that
because everybody who met her except
Louis loathed her um because she was
very abrasive uh she was very
rude um when she was well and there was
one exception to this he had a an old
pupil called Roger lanel and green and
when it was that Joy was desperately ill
with cancer the LEL and greens took
Lewis and Joy on a cruise in the
mediterranian and um and that was
obviously a completely wonderful summer
when when the the four of them were
together and it was the closest thing
leis really ever had to a normal
friendship I think at Summer with the do
we know anything from his ratings any
Diaries even his books about why he
loved her so much I think it was an
intellectual thing uh to start with he
was impressed that this woman who had
been a communist atheist was persuaded
of the truth of the Christian religion
by reading him so there was a bit of
egotism probably there was a passionate
sexual attraction which is very clear
from what he writes about um in his
diary and in his letters to her he I
mean if you have to Define somebody his
sexual tastes he he was a sedom
masochist um as a Young Man he used to
sign his letters phom mastics the lover
of the Whip and this is not the CS Lewis
I am familiar with and he I mean even I
mean he wasn't gay but um the professor
of Greek was put in um a recent book by
Daisy Dunn about the um Oxford in those
days before the war before the first
world war they all went off when he was
an undergraduate he used to go around
undergraduate parties saying if I give
somebody a shilling Lady of me a
whipping so I mean he he was obsessed by
uh punishment and she clearly was happy
to enter into that Mrs uh Mrs David
Lewis was writing when Hitler was still
in power how did the politics of the 30s
affect his work it's a very good
question that um as you probably know
for a long time his best friend was JRR
to keen and one of the things which put
that friendship under threat was that
tol Keen like many Catholics at that
date sympathized with the
fascists and when the Spanish war broke
out Spanish Civil War he was wholly on
the side of General Franco whereas Lewis
took the view which he expressed very
loudly once in an Oxford pub and
somebody punched him in the face famous
poet called Roy Campbell uh that the
Republic in Spain though communist and
though atheist was the elected
government which is true um he
he was pretty detached from the
news uh there's a very good entry in his
brother's diary his brother lived with
them
um it says wary Lewis uh a big row at
breakfast with Jack that's what he
called Lewis um after about half an hour
shouting we realized that Lewis thought
that Tito was the king of Greece so I
mean that's how much he knew about
politics didn't stop him having very
passionate AR
sometimes Andrew thank you so much for
joining spectator
TV that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode I would also
like to thank our sponsors cancord
genuity wealth management Kord are
experienced wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support during challenging times visit
kendow wealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and you join
us again next
[Music]
week